you see in the center a Spitfire  commanded by Squadron Leader Duncan  Mason and he's flanked by hurricanes and  on the outside we'll see two further  split past let's listen to the roar of  those engines  and memories for the Queen's generation  who would have heard those aircraft  flying over regularly and the dogfights  that took place  and so many people looking now at the  past and the present  Huracan and a distinctive typhoon flying  over their Spitfire just leading the way  Spitfires probably had the greatest  element of profile but here three  typhoons which do the same Quick  Reaction job in protecting United  Kingdom's  skies  and following that the Royal Air Force  who are forming the guard in the full  court below her Majesty the Queen will  prepare to far  a further Joie as the aircraft turned  back towards Coningsby and to their  various stations